i don't care if i only had a hundred
thousand i'm spending 50 000
because this is the whole point of
working really really hard is spending
my money on stuff that will make my
family happy and they'll talk about
forever
i feel like i can rule the world i know
i could be what
all right welcome to the episode we
actually talked about like maybe eight
legitimately wonderful ideas we talked
about privacy startups we talked about
ghost.org which is a wordpress
competitor that we actually think is
going to be a 100 million dollar plus
company
we talked about bird flow.io which is a
new business that just started like two
weeks ago that's quite interesting what
else did we talk about
uh we talked about ikea hacking which is
the art of
souping up and upgrading your basic
furniture into something dope using ikea
parts
and what you know that little trend that
might actually be something that you
could
build a little build a business around
this is going to be an interesting
episode because we actually rattled off
a ton of stuff it just went from thing
to thing to thing to thing
uh damn sam tells you
why you should be spending three times
as much on your engagement ring as
you're planning to
five times as much i spent five times as
much and i don't regret it at all and i
actually think everyone should so
listen to the end that's the uh that
bits at the very end at 54 minutes i
think
give it a listen and also go and click
that subscribe button on itunes and that
follow button on spotify
because we're going to be launching some
more episodes that are interesting next
week
and go subscribe to the youtube channel
we just had our first video that had
a hundred thousand views on youtube so
we're getting big over there let's do it
um all right sean grab your iphone for
me
i'm gonna talk to you about something
but first i'm going to show you
so all right go to your iphone go to
settings
type in privacy and click privacy
type in privacy all right all right and
if you're following along on an iphone
do this for me
this isn't like a track that's like a
real thing all right click location
services
and then scroll all the way to the
bottom where it says system services
yep all right after you click that
scroll
halfway down to where it says
significant locations do you see that
yeah click that and it asks you for your
password probably
it just face id'd me all right all right
now your lotus
your latest location it might say vegas
or nevada or something click it
yep so what you're going to see is
my precise location your precise
location is
tracked forever so since you used your
phone
and you could clear your history but you
see how it's like tracking all your
stuff by the way
i i clicked it it says arrived via 27
minute drive
it's like it knows exactly when i
arrived and how i arrived because it
used apple maps or like it uses a bunch
of stuff it'll tell you like how you got
there it'll tell you what apps
you're using when you're getting there
it'll tell you all types of interesting
stuff
now the reason i'm talking about this is
i want to tell you a story about privacy
and i wanted to show you like why this
is crazy because you like
knew that like if i told you like
intellectually you'd be like yeah of
course
oh your iphone tracks you yeah of course
uh so i just wanted
to show you it is weird to see it like
that it's weird to see it and the reason
i'm bringing this up is i read this
story about this guy named kyle mcdonald
and in 2011
he basically did this story where he
well actually let me tell you this first
so he was interested in
in privacy and he thought he read this
line and it said can you imagine living
a life without any private information
where with no private bank statements no
private files on your computer
um it's hard to understand right but
what if you actually ask that question a
little bit differently
so do you trust the government do you
trust large banks do you trust facebook
do you trust google do you
trust these large entities with your
information because that's kind of like
the same thing it just asks a little bit
differently
and so he did this first test where he
created this thing called key tweeter
and every 140 characters on his keyboard
automatically tweeted
uh so like there was no privacy because
he wanted to see what was the world like
without privacy and he took it a step
further and so he went to an
apple store in brooklyn and they had 50
computers and he
installed an app on all 50 computers
that automatically took a picture every
like 30 or
60 seconds and any time it detected a
face
it would send him the pictures and he
published it as like an art exhibit
an art thing of like look at what people
look like when they're looking in
computers at a laptop in apple and
after publishing that the secret service
raided his home
uh and apple apple contacted the service
they raided his home they took his
computers they did a thorough
investigation they declined to prosecute
but they definitely could have done
something
and i thought that that was amazing when
i started thinking about that i'm like
isn't that crazy
that i am i would be i would be upset
too if someone took my picture i
wouldn't be upset to call the police but
i would be upset i wouldn't like it
isn't that crazy that i'm upset about
that but
i like type in all my information uh
throughout the web or i let someone
track me and
it's quite an interesting way and i
thought what's another way and so i
discovered this little hack i'm like
when i see that
it actually changed my perception and so
there's this issue going on where i
actually think
these privacy startups are going to be
huge in 10 20 30 years
now my problem that i'm having
personally is i'm actually struggling to
find different solutions that need to
like different ways to solve or
different problems that need to be
solved but i agree with this general
premise of like when i just did that
experiment where i showed you your
tracking stuff
and when i just like read this guy's uh
art story i was like
yeah i'm totally not okay with that i
don't like that right
but you're trying something out that was
like this you go
say your tweet you go imagine if you
walked into go ahead
yeah so let's just say that you're
walking around the street and a company
walks you into their office and they go
check this out and they give you a file
cabinet you open this file cabinet
and there's 10 000 pictures of you and
your family taken throughout the last
five years
and you had no idea those pictures were
being taken how would you
feel about that of course you'd feel
violated
now they would say they would say look
you were in public and i would say yeah
i know
i i was in public i can't be too angry
but i still
don't feel right about this now that's
exactly how what happens with your data
you know that you're opting into things
you know you're you're consenting
but sometimes you don't realize what
you're getting into and you if you
actually truly knew what was happening
you might regret it
and i think that the next generations of
humans
uh like the guys who are five and ten
years old now i actually think that
they're not gonna like this stuff
and we're gonna see a lot of products
that come out that fight it because i
think that
like when you think of like oh wow you
used to be able to smoke in a restaurant
in the 1990s i mean i remember when i
was a kid i could smoke in a restaurant
or you you'd be smoking a restaurant
now we think that's asinine i think that
the privacy stuff now we're actually
going to look back in 20 years and be
like
i can't believe that that was you're
able to do that so anyway
i wanted to start it off with that uh
that experiment
i like that uh i like that story a lot
and i'm with you we've talked about
different quote-unquote privacy-focused
startups ranging from like
privacy.com to duckduckgo and how that's
actually privacy.com by the way
become like a real kind of like sort of
competitor to google in a
obviously in a niche but hey it made it
it made it out
after you know 10 years against google
um
and we've talked about different
different versions of this whether it's
browsers
uh phones a lot of the crypto stuff is
based on these
these same principles right like you own
your data
um and you just you custody it yourself
rather than trusting this like kind of
central
company to do to hold it for you and um
so i'm definitely with you that i think
that some really big companies gonna be
there because
people really give a [__] about this and
you could tell people give a [__] about
this like it's ironic you were saying
go to your apple iphone settings because
if you want if you go down the street in
san francisco
you're gonna see huge billboards and it
just says privacy
and it's just apple and there's a phone
blocking out your face
like this like somebody holding a phone
and you can't see their face and that's
their whole ad and that's their
differentiation that's their shtick
about like what they care about at the
super bowl they had that ad
of somebody just looking at their phone
like typing like kind of like a text
message to somebody they're just
laughing uncontrollably but they never
explain what it is because it's like hey
that's your information
and um and so apple is like basically
bet the farm on privacy as like their
core attribute that they're going to be
providing to customers
like the number one value prop now and
um
but you know here you go you go into you
go into your phone settings and it's
like hey
yeah we've tracked your location and you
can share that and here's here's all the
different services you've shared that
with
um you know here and they are trying to
fight back like you've you've probably
heard the facebook stuff that happened
but
if you're not advertising on facebook
you you shouldn't actually realize how
big of a deal it was
you should explain what's going on
because even i
i don't own an advertising business
anymore but i did even i was a little
bit under
under educated but it's actually a an
incredibly big deal and this is an
incredibly big deal for
a consumer but also as business people
last week we talked about this
inflection with the ncaa athlete thing
this is actually a new inflection
it actually helps guys like me who owned
an advertising business but i don't not
anymore
right yeah so so basically facebook's
this you know obviously it's the
advertising juggernauts facebook and
google
and with facebook facebook relied on
having obviously detailed targeting
information about you people always said
oh it's creepy
um you know your iphone my iphone's
listening to me
and uh and by the way do you know the
explanation of why
of how that works it's like dude i was
just talking to my friend about this and
then
you know and now it's showing up in my
my facebook ads and like the
reason why is because your your friend
has searched for a thing or interacted
with a product
and then they know that you were close
to your friend your phones are in close
proximity and so they start showing you
ads that have been like your friends
that your friends have been interested
in because they know that that works and
there's a chance that you had talked
about it
and then you know out of 30 times that
that you didn't talk about it you just
saw an ad it just
went by you and then the one time it's
the thing you guys were talking about it
stands out and you remember that and you
think facebook's
listening to you but nonetheless um
facebook basically had the biggest
targeting machine in the world right you
could segment by
state by religion by whatever and then
they've slowly stripped away some of
those things as they got in trouble
for you know like privacy with the
election about what what sorts of things
you can target on
but fundamentally facebook knew more
about you than you knew about yourself
facebook knows before you're pregnant
right facebook knows you're pregnant
before you know you're pregnant
and it knows based on your behaviors it
knows based on your interest and knows
based on many things
uh you know a lot of stuff about you and
so what happened is apple basically
stripped the one thing facebook needed
um
it lets you facebook basically lets you
opt out of data tracking so
when you update to the new ios or sorry
apple did when you update to the new ios
system it says hey
do you want to share all your data
you're just like no
and that one no took away facebook's
entire like kind of like
knowledge about you as a customer and so
you've opted out of this tracking and so
now when you go visit websites facebook
doesn't get that data back to it
it doesn't get that that information
back and so as a facebook advertiser if
you're in ecommerce right now
all the numbers just show sort of
changed overnight uh like even when you
send it
you show a facebook ad to somebody they
click it and they go buy a product from
you facebook's only catching like 60
of those conversions it doesn't know
about the other 40 because they've opted
out of tracking or it didn't work
and so uh facebook all of a sudden it's
kind of like scrambling to figure out
all right
how the heck are we gonna like deliver
the same value to our advertisers which
is our main business model
without the it's like you know fighting
with one hand tied behind your back now
uh halfway through the fight and so
that's that's sort of what apple did to
facebook and facebook tried to fight it
in court
and they tried to do all this pr where
they're like you're hurting small
businesses and in reality they are
you are you are yeah but you know net
net
it's good for the consumer to not have
facebook just build this like
super rich profile of your every move
and your every taste and your every
tendency
uh just so that businesses can advertise
to you better
so if you're listening and you've got a
privacy or or
something like related to this idea i
would love to learn about it reach out
to us
i'm i'm interested um i got i got a few
more ideas do you want to go you want to
you want to go after one uh yeah go for
it you do one
all right i'm gonna tell you one
interesting one i'll tell you two
um the first is called ghost ghost.org
have you heard of ghost.org
i've used ghost yeah okay so i'm
interested in this ghost
it's a wordpress meet sub stack is the
best maybe explanation so it's a
wordpress site
uh it's its own platform so it's a
wordpress competitor
but they offer a handful of features
like you can accept money for a paywall
uh article they have a few more features
i actually don't know all the features
that they have
and why people so let's say the use case
is you want to spin up a website for
yourself
you can use ghost you want to spin up an
email newsletter that's either free or
paid or both
you can use ghost instead of substack or
you could want to spit up a community a
paid community you could use a ghost
and so basically ghost is this open
source version of
sub stack it's this low cost instead of
let's say subset they take 10 of all
your revenue
ghosts just says hey pay us 10 bucks a
month and we're happy and so they don't
take they don't take a percentage of
your revenue so for a lot of people that
could be thousands of dollars a month
that you're saving if you use ghost and
they have different tiers so 10
a month 30 a month 80 to 200 a month and
so there's a few interesting things
about it but first like the guy behind
it is intriguing so he launched it as a
non-profit which i actually think is
stupid but it probably was good for like
pr
and a lot of people actually worked on
it for free to help him i think
definitely he should switch
but it's actually making three and a
half million dollars a year
and he uses a ton of people like free
labor like people who just want to
contribute
and i think he actually has um staff but
what he does is if you go to ghost.org
slash about you he actually reveals all
of his revenue and i think that's
interesting
because i was going through this and i
uh
i'm a an investor in a in a
company called convertkit maybe you are
too i don't remember but
um this company called convertkit they
do
something like 30 million in recurring
revenue right now they're in the value
of
like you could say that maybe they're
worth 200 to 30 million dollars based
off of like public comp so
10 times um revenue-ish and
i was looking through ghost.org's
numbers
they're very similar to what convertkit
was about four years ago when they just
got started
and so my prediction and i want to go on
record by saying this is a i think this
is awesome and b
i actually think that this could be a
multi-hundred million dollar company in
the making
and you could watch this guy build it in
public and i think it's interesting also
he had one major quote
so typically people who build these
types of things are kind of like nerdy
and
engineer-like and which means they're
sometimes like reserved and held back
and i
which i which i like but he had a great
quote that i read he goes someone goes
what's your major advice for people
getting started he goes honestly my
single biggest piece of advice would
probably be to stop looking for so much
advice and shut the [__] up and go build
something
so what do you think about this company
do you agree in my prediction that this
could actually could be a multi-100
million dollar business
okay kind of boring but i agree right
it's more entertaining when we disagree
but i
i totally agree i i used ghost for many
of the reasons you talked about a i was
intrigued i thought their story was
interesting i liked that they're kind of
like kind of like pirates they were sort
of like
just going against the grain on a bunch
of stuff that they were doing product is
good
uh not super simple to use it's kind of
like
like i also find you know frankly i find
wordpress to be a little bit confusing
if you want wordpress is
incredibly confusing yeah like it's kind
of like easy to get the first thing
going and then to get it to do what you
want takes like a lot of
stuff um i'm surprised this is as small
as it is so 3.7 million annual run rate
i'm surprised it's that small because
ghost has been around for a while
four years so so i don't think that's i
don't think it's that impressive where
it is
but it's sort of like a duck that go uh
where i'm like
i believe it i first i believe that
these guys are not going to quit so i
think that's like you know the first
thing these guys aren't going away
and when they don't go away they are
very differentiated and
uniquely positioned where they're going
to pick up like 10
or so of this entire wave of like like
self-publishing
that's going on with sub stack and
others um and i
like i'm more excited about this
business than i am about substance
uh 100 i completely agree with you and i
i i
the the reason i'm bringing this up to
listeners is not necessarily this is a
new idea that they can go and do
but if you want to go and watch this
person build uh
he updates the blog every month and he
reveals most all their revenue
they're also a non-profit so if you dig
around if you google like ghost
foundation 501c you probably can see
their total financials because
nonprofits disclose that but
really cool company that you could watch
being built it's still small now but
it's going to be fun to watch this being
become
huge over the next four years yeah i'm
with you on that
um all right i got some uh ideas so one
is from trends actually this ikea
hacking thing so
yeah um so so i saw this in in y'all's
trends like whatever the weekly
newsletter thing that you guys put out
and um
i thought this was pretty fascinating so
what is ikea hacking ikea hacking is
when you buy something
that's sort of like a basic looking
piece of furniture and then because
ikea is like a what's it called totally
modular store like any piece of
any piece of furniture it's like all the
wheels are kind of like
they accept this one like one peg so you
can go swap
50 different wheels onto the same piece
of furniture or same thing with the
handle or the facade or the like you
know
the top the table top the glass top
whatever right so it has like this
um uniform nature to it which lets you
just swap parts almost like minecraft or
roblox or something like that
and so ikea hacking is the art of taking
something that's sort of a simple plain
jane looking ikea piece of furniture
and then you go to the store and you
just buy different little uh
upgrades you know like you're souping up
a car on uh on pimp my ride
and then you but you're pimping out your
your your dresser or your your desk or
whatever it is and you make something
that looks pretty sick
and actually it was just like you know
worth of random ikea parts that if you
assemble them correctly they take you
from this before picture
to this after picture if it's the
youtube video put up the before and
after that's in from the trends thing
it's awesome like
it just looks so simple like very basic
looking thing to like a really cool
looking thing
and this was all just done using ikea
parts so i have some ideas around this
but did i first did i even accurately
describe it
yeah you described it correctly and the
way that we discovered this or i i think
i mean i i used this four years ago when
we first started our company basically i
found this subreddit called ikea hacking
and what i did was i bought a 150
kitchen countertop it was basically like
a
a really nice wood block that's all i
mean that was like a like a countertop
but i and then i just went and got some
legs from from like a whole totally
different thing this countertop you're
actually supposed to lay on like granite
or like a like a like a countertop and i
just but i just screwed legs on it and i
put it in the middle of our room and
that was like our kitchen table at our
office
and that's and i think i started talking
to stuff about ikea hacking it's very
fascinating i don't know what the
business ideas are though
okay so here's the business idea so
first it's r ikea hacks it's got 78 000
members on reddit so
back to the episode we did with greg
eisenberg where he talked about
unbundling reddit
this is a classic example so shout out
to greg basically
i would look at a community like this
and i'd say huh these people are pretty
passionate about what's uh
what they're doing here and like these
photos are kind of amazing these would
make for great ads this would make for
great content just seeing
uh seeing this right and so i would just
go to r
reddit.comr slash r ikea hacks
and then i would sort by like top top
post
you know for the year or something like
that and just go get a sense of like
what's there
and then click comments and read all the
top comments of all the top posts
so i think you could do a few things
here right i think you could do
so i would then take many of the proven
business models and then i would like
apply them here
so if i was getting started what would i
do to start i would start by saying look
i don't know the exact business model
but what i do know is that this is great
content
so i would create an instagram account
right away right because the first thing
that you got to know is that
most people don't bury their head in
reddit they're not going to find all
these new subreddit even someone like me
who
uses reddit every day i didn't know
about this subreddit
and so let alone my sister who will
never use reddit
and she'll only use instagram and so
like the first thing i would do is i
would
immediately create an instagram account
that's just posting the ikea hacks the
best pictures from from reddit basically
just plagiarize it and just put it there
and then just credit the username from
reddit in every photo
as a photo credit just just just so you
don't get in trouble
yeah just so i would say what are you
talking about i was given credit right
there and it's like dude
you're ripping this off um so that's the
first thing i would do i would try to
get that to like 50 to 100 000
followers on instagram because that's
now my asset that's my audience that's
interested in this thing
that i can then leak out different
products
so it could be a course like a simple
like
100 200 course that's like your guide to
ikea hacking
it could be like individual courses it's
like the bedroom course the
the off home office course the home
garage you know the the
garage gym course or whatever right like
maybe different modules that i would do
so i would
maybe think about courses i would think
about maybe i could sell these as kits
so like maybe i could save you the
hassle of having to go to ikea
but like figure out oh i need this knob
and then this little paper thing
and then this other thing and then those
three together are what you use to like
make this vintage looking dresser
maybe i would just sell the vintage
looking dresser kit and it's it might
just be as simple as a recipe
walk into ikea go to the section 198
point c
and go pick up this item right um and so
it might be something like that
i don't know what i would do but i do
think there's like a small bootstrap
business and this is a good business for
somebody who is
genuinely passionate about this right so
like how do you take
what i'll call your like okay this is
not meant to be offensive but like
there's a lot of hobbies that are like
basic [__] hobbies
so what's a basic [__] hobby basically
tommy is a hobby that you think is
unique to you
it's like saying like no you're [__]
disgusting no offense uh
like any time you say no offense it's
like it would be
just brace yourself for some offense
yeah no don't [__] hate me no offense
so so no events here so like for guys
the basic [__] hobby is like sports oh
bro i love i love the nba yeah you and
like
80 million other people right now right
so it's not like a unique hobby
so you can't how do you turn your
passion into business well
it's not a unique passion so you're
probably gonna have like a me too
business
unless you think of a new angle and so
another basic [__] hobbies like oh i
love interior
decorating it's like cool you and like
90 90 million other people who like to
watch
hdtv and just judge stuff or like you're
happy to scroll on instagram pretty
looking things and push like
well i think that's why if you if you
look at it from this angle with like
ikea hacks you're finding a niche and
you're building your own audience on
that
on that like that one kind of trend and
then maybe you can release some kind of
subscription product
education product ddc product like
something to that audience
and now you've turned your basic we
already talked about the basic [__]
version of this for us which was the
knees over toes guy
um yeah another another example of
working out dude
yeah another example of this is phillips
hughes
phillips hughes light bulbs crazy
subreddit that is like has a rabid fan
base i've actually
like lighting or something right what is
it phillips hues
it started as just a bulb that was and
you would say alexa make the bulbs
or you know make the living room purple
um but then they have like
50 other products now and people like
have all these blogs and they're
actually making good money i bet you
like apartment therapy or like one of
these bigger
brands actually owns one of these blogs
i'd have to scroll down and look at who
the copywriter owns the copyright but
basically it's blogs on
where to put the lights like under the
bed in order to make it feel cool
right an example of who did this well is
house of highlights i don't know if you
followed them on instagram but they're
they're big basically they they took
espn sportscenter
which was like this 30 minute television
show highly produced and all i was doing
was showing you the best highlights of
the day
and so back in the day you know like
sports would happen all day and in the
evening
or the morning the next morning you
would watch sportscenter to catch up
through the best highlights right it's
like just the sugar and
house of highlights smartly realized hey
you know we can just post those as like
10 second clips on instagram
as soon as they happen all day and like
i can basically have like two people
two like people who like the nba just
run this account and this account can
grow to like a million people so the guy
like omar created this thing
i i i think literally owns it yeah so he
ends up selling it to bleacher report
and uh and runs it there they run it now
i bet you whatever you sold it for you
sold it for way too little um
and so like you know overtime did kind
of the same thing um
but but anyways that's like an example
of taking these like
how do you take this content that's not
your content it's not original content
uh it's in this like kind of basic [__]
hobby and then you turn it into like
a media media property that you own and
then you own that audience and you can
figure out what you want to do from
there
so there's this couple who uh they got
popular
because right before the pandemic
started it was a french guy and his
american girlfriend
who are now husband and wife and they
started baking croissants in their
apartment
and then they brought it to work and
they like sold them to their friends or
their co-workers
uh and then eventually they created an
instagram and they went viral
and the apartment that i'm staying in
right now
bought like pre-ordered you have to
pre-order eight weeks out because
they're sold out for weeks and weeks and
they're just baking this
these croissants and cookies out of
their apartment and the guy who owns my
apartment
got them and then ended up going out of
the country and he's like hey you can
actually have my order it's like 90
of like these fancy croissants and so on
sunday i'm going to get those fancy
croissants
and i invited dave nemets the founder of
bleacher report and his wife to come
over and eat these like
i was like hey you want to cut these are
like fancy girl croissants like i don't
unders
at the time i didn't know the story but
like for some reason i think this is a
big deal you want to come over and eat
these with your kids
so i'll be eating croissants with the
founder of bleach report on sunday and i
can ask him the story about house
highlights
that's yeah do please do it's an amazing
buy by him like like
mad credit to them for picking this up
before before espn or anybody else
i think by the way he listens to the
podcast or at least he like
talks to us on twitter a bunch um and so
he seems great and bleachy report
i saw his talk at hustlecon very
impressive
um like the way they kind of like won
and they survived i just remember this
one anecdote he told which was he was
like
yeah we basically like every other
content site
was kind of like okay i might butcher
this just because i'm trying to remember
a talk from three years ago but here's
what i remember him saying every other
like
sports news website was just talking
about whatever was interesting to them
they're all kind of putting out the same
content
he's like we needed to be smarter right
like we needed to say every
hour a writer is going to spend we don't
have the same number of writers or
budget
so they need to spend writing articles
that are going to get more traffic than
anybody else
and so he would just reverse engineer it
so he like they would just study google
searches and they would say oh
everybody's searching
when what time is the nfl draft he's
like so we would
immediately like have like the number
one ranking thing on google for
what time is nfl draft where to watch it
and how to watch it and what's going to
happen in the draft just like this kind
of
filler content on a website and he's
like people really like the draft okay
we're going to go like all in on the
draft
and we're going to write 10 times more
content about the draft because that's
what there's a big appetite for
that espn is like under serving and so i
thought it was pretty awesome how they
took kind of like a supply demand
approach to it instead of like an artsy
right like an artsy approach of like oh
you know this is what this is
we're a journalistic publication and we
should uh we should
write the hard-hitting pieces about
whatever or like you know well here's
what i'm passionate about it's like no
they like
took a science approach to it which i
liked and then the other founder
went and did that he had a non-compete
after he sold bleacher report so he
couldn't do sports anymore but he
started a media company called bustle
which is like women's content so all
types of
articles but like an example of his long
tail
search strategy he deployed the same
strategy so like if you google like
what happens when i get my period while
i'm on the beach like bustle will show
up number one it's like there's only
gonna be like
a hundred people a month or something
that's searched for that if i
have no idea but like that i think i had
heard through him that was one of the
examples
or if you google things like that you'll
come across bustle and they do
like over 100 million in revenue and so
it still works
right and by the way one insert was just
pivoting off the instagram thing we
talked about this in the past but
there's some new news so
we should bring it up we talked about
this um
this woman who's an influencer she's a
fitness influencer on instagram
kayla i think it's cenes or something i
don't know exactly
no i think it's it's every woman
listening to this is just gonna be like
what the [__] guys i think it's it's new
what there was something else we we
tried to pronounce that we just like
couldn't
it was just like a like i don't know
some some fancy luxury brand
uh for purses or something like burmese
yeah yeah she wears herpes of bags um
so anyway she has this app so she
basically took this instagram following
it was just posting like workout clips
on instagram and stuff
her and her boyfriend i think or her
husband i don't remember who was well
before the app
they were just selling a pdf sarah my
wife exactly she bought it for 29. my
sister-in-law has the pdf and she was
just using this pdf for like is it like
the
the beachbody or if i don't forget what
it's called it's like some some kind of
like 30-day program
yeah that's our 30-minute workout that
was like you know from from this girl
and she was buying the pdf
then they turn it into an app right so
they turn it into an app app starts
doing
great um my wife is a subscriber you pay
100 bucks a year and then you open up
the app and it's basically like
from what i remember you open up the app
there's like five women who are like the
trainers and it's like
one is like very muscular one is like
very just like thin
one is like half kind of like toned or
whatever another one has like a huge
butt
it's like which body do you want and go
follow their program
and so you would just pick it and then
you would get like daily workouts kind
of like a video that was like very good
and so anyways that app was doing like i
think they had done over 100 million
dollars revenue i don't know if that's
annual or cumulative but
they just sold so i don't know if you
have the details in front of you but
they just sold for like 400 million
dollars or something right
like they just exited um exited the app
this week yeah for 400 million they sold
to this company called ifit which is
about to go public
they said they were doing 100 million in
revenue um
pretty amazing no-brainer to buy
definitely worth it i think and it's
pretty weird that 100 million if you're
doing 100 million in revenue
you uh you know you sold for for only
400 million so
it's pretty low multiple for like a
digital product but uh yeah they're
probably not i don't think so
probably spending a ton on on marketing
okay um
yeah i i maybe maybe not i mean she had
13 million followers and it is based on
her
uh thing on her uh on her following
um can i tell you about an idea that
someone just sent to me and i thought it
was pretty amazing
okay look at the thing called bird flow
in the dock so it's called bird flow dot
io did you click on that
i saw you text me about it this morning
but i haven't checked out this so tell
me about it
okay so this guy said it to me he goes
hey i had this like software company
and it was trying to do all these
problems and solve all like it's called
crowd flow or something like that and
he's like it's a i spent three years
working on it
and then i just said [__] it i'm just
gonna create a really micro small app
i'm gonna build it in two weeks it just
does one thing really well it's called
bird flow and if you click it it says
marketing automation for twitter
but basically i'll i'll tell you like it
does three different things but the
main thing is everyone who clicks follow
on your profile
it automatically sends them a message
and you could say anything in that
message
like hey thanks for following or hey
thanks for following check out my
website
and i installed it he's charging 29
i installed it and it's awesome it's
awesome it's awesome
i love these little micro sas tools i
think it's so
neat this is exactly how buffer got
started and that's a multi-hundred
million dollar business
right yeah i like the the micro sas tool
that does one simple thing
that helps you win on a platform you're
already like trying to win on
that's the key right so like i'm already
trying to win on twitter i'm trying to
win on instagram trying to win on reddit
whatever
and if you could build the micro sas
tool it's like here's you know other
examples of them
uh there's uh what's it called jungle
scout
which is for amazon so let's say you're
trying to win as an fba seller
on on amazon so you're selling a product
on amazon jungle scout is this
app you can use and basically when
you're searching any amazon
like search search result you can use
you can open up jungle scout and it'll
basically tell you how much
that product is worth how much how much
search volume there is for it how
competitive it is
to be in that niche and how much money
they think that product is making so
that you can find
winning products that are like high
demand low competition
and then you could build a fba you know
an fba business in that niche
and so it's a simple sas tool i think
jungle scout does some stupid amount of
revenue too because they were recently
partially acquired by pe in the hundreds
of millions of dollars of valuation
greg mercer is good friends with neville
and in austin and uh he like
uh this is i guess public i mean he's
got like a plane and [__]
uh so whatever it was sold for like
neville will post pictures going to like
tell you ride in
uh private jet and i'm like dude who's
the jazz guy or he's the jungle scout
guy
the guy who sold part of the company who
started it gotcha
yeah so so super simple tool that just
helped you in there and they just built
they just kind of like dominate that one
niche of like
fba you know fba selling or in this case
twitter automations
right so oh somebody and so i like this
a lot i need something like this
uh for me because i'm trying to
basically grow my audience on twitter
and then
cool the less work i can do the better
right like i love
digital sales people all right a digital
sales person that's what i think about
when i think about landing pages or like
this like little like automations that's
a digital sales person as somebody who's
going to work 24 7 for me
for zero cost or you know in this case
whatever it was 29
a month um that's their salary and
they're gonna do exactly what i say
every single time predictably and uh
they're just gonna generate more value
for me and so
i look at my landing page like a digital
sales person i look at my automations
like convertkit
things like that as digital sales people
and um
yeah this is a really cool one i like
this a lot now you can see this getting
really annoying i mean people hate
getting these auto dms but
uh it still will work yeah yeah it it
might be
annoying but i actually just made mine
it just says hey exclamation point
thanks for following
now here's the problem that i already
found so i it's already sent out
a couple hundred messages for me i guess
i get maybe 500 to 1 000 new followers a
day
this uh i feel like a douche saying that
this
let's say it a couple women replied yeah
so a couple like really attractive women
applied
and or replied saying like hey what's
going on you know
like your work basically they apply yeah
so like these like
attractive women replied and i was like
[__]
i don't want like anyone to get the
wrong idea
to think that i'm hollering just at them
or that i'm hollering at all you know
and so i didn't reply to them but i was
like oh my gosh like let's see i
actually
might be able to this could definitely
get me in trouble a little bit i could
totally see it right when that when that
kind of i sent you that message it was
kind of weird right
it was hilarious um yeah i could see you
know the same thing with
somebody else pointed this out too which
is like let's say you write a thread
that goes viral
you might get 5000 followers you're
going to send out what 5 000 auto dms
and then get like
2 000 random replies back it's gonna
like kind of ruin your inbox
and maybe get you banned from twitter i
don't know because it'll just rate limit
you so
so i think there's some problems with it
maybe maybe this guy's built in
some rules like for me i would only want
to do this i would only want to dm
somebody who
has over x followers or that i you know
i already follow or something like that
so then it kind of like limits the
number of people that does it too
you need it to be like hey you know only
if it's a you know farmer looking white
boy then send this so i don't get in
trouble with my wife you know like i
needed to be like
this guy needs to have like you know
patel or gupta at his last name
if it's gonna send this auto dm so my
indian fanboys can uh
can get these messages from me but not
everybody else yeah
i could see it get me in trouble um all
right you want to do another one
yeah let's do one uh okay little idea
that i think is kind of interesting
um i don't have a ton to say about the
business but it's more like
this is a cool way to get ideas so this
is my first time traveling with uh with
babies
and uh traveling babies it's like you
know all the things you would expect
like on the plane
you know kid pooped through his clothes
had to change it
you know like on a tray table because we
couldn't stand up because the fastest
seatbelt sign the person next to us
looking at is like we're gross and
that is disgusting i mean you are
exactly i know i know
i agree um but there's a bunch of
problems so like we had to take our car
seats right because you can't just like
be like
i'll get there you know i used to pack
light i used to be like cool i'll get
there i just need my phone i'll call an
uber get to my hotel
if i'm missing something i'll just buy
it there and with this with kids it's
like the opposite it's like
can't even get in an uber because you
have to like have a car seat
all that stuff so i saw this business
called baby quip that i thought was kind
of cool
it's again one of our like telltale
signs is
any business that shows up at the top of
a google's a popular google search
but the website looks like it was last
updated in like 1996
um those are businesses that print money
and so it's like congratulations you
have identified a money printer and so i
don't know how successful baby clip is
but i would suspect it's pretty
good as a bootstrap business and what it
does is it's basically a marketplace so
i could say hey i just landed in las
vegas
i need two car seats i don't want to lug
two car seats
check them in uh you know like on the
fly like you know drag them to the
airport check them in take them home
like
just meet me at the airport with a car
seat that i can just install into a
rental car
or i can saw into it to an uber or
whatever uh and then like let me rent it
for four days and then when i'm leaving
come pick it back up from the airport
and so that's what baby quip is it's a
baby equipment
but it's a marketplace where people will
bring you what you need you need a
stroller i got a stroller for you don't
plug that heavy thing around
just use mine when i'm here people are
making a lot of money just google
searching i was like
i was google searching and again it's a
very good content play
i was google searching baby travel
packing list
so i was like what do i even what am i
forgetting here and so they had a blog
post i was like here's all the things
you need to pack for your baby and then
at the bottom it's like by the way if
you don't want to pack your stroller and
car seats because they're heavy as hell
like you know you could just use baby
clip and get it when you're there
and i was like click through and i was
like this is cool and so i just thought
this is like a very clever business that
is a look for problems look for
annoyances look for inconveniences and
then those become
your opportunities if you can design a
solution around them so i just have a
clever little business
this is awesome so baby quip is actually
it's a peer-to-peer marketplace so i
don't think you actually said that
i thought it was the company that would
give you stuff no it's just like
jane whose kid outgrew her car seat and
she realizes she can make
you know 200 a month just renting it out
to people
as long as she's willing to go drop it
off and pick it up from the airport
i have these guys raised money they've
been around for a while
they haven't it doesn't look like
they've raised money um but yeah they
you know they are basically like just a
kind of like a uh
looks like a bootstrap business from
everything i could tell launched in
2016.
they've had over 30 000 orders uh i
think they did a crowdfunding
campaign at some point so maybe they're
and they're on shark tank
this is kind of interesting now i i'm
not convinced that this is gonna this
can be a huge huge thing
but what is actually what is actually
interesting is let's go to new york
it tells you how many reservations
someone has ever had i bet you that
there could be like some mom
who's just dominated like a la or a new
york scene
like can just rank really high on all
the uh all the big cities and lend out
all their stuff and so what it does is
it tells you how much it so what
basically what happens is you land in
new york you
but before you land you tell baby quip
you hire camila shannon
who's the top in new york she's rented
her stuff out 773 times
and she'll bring you any gear that you
need and you could see all the gear that
she has and she costs 40 to 60
to deliver the stuff to you plus there's
gear for there's a
a car seat for ten dollars a day there's
a play pin for forty dollars a day
there's 15
pound dumbbells for five dollars a day
there's a
this is crazy this is awesome this is
awesome this is a great find
yeah so so another example of this by
the way have you
used or or probably not used but you're
familiar with them i'm assuming
teachers pay teachers no what's that
you've never heard of teachers pay
teachers no why
it doesn't doesn't matter this is just
like one of those things that you know
about
because it's just awesome and uh so
google teachers pay teachers so what
this is is
oh my god if you if you remember like a
teacher spends a huge amount of time
every teacher spends a huge amount of
time like creating their lesson plans
and quizzes and tests and they have to
like keep recreating like
content basically for their little
classroom of 30 people it's pretty
inefficient right
so you go you you teach kids all day
already kind of an exhausting thing
now you go home and you um you have to
grade papers
you have to come up with tomorrow's
lesson plan and then you have to design
the quiz for thursday's quiz
then you have next friday's test so you
have all this stuff you're just
constantly this content treadmill
and what teachers pay teachers did that
was genius was they said look
that's a lot of effort and you may not
be the best person
at coming up with the lesson plan or the
quiz for this science topic
so why don't we just create a
marketplace where any teacher can list
their lesson plans their quizzes their
tests
and you can just find go instead of just
making your own go on here for 10 bucks
and go buy the best science thing for a
fourth grader trying to learn about you
know geology right now
and you just go buy the thing for 10
bucks and you've saved four hours of
time
and so it's like a great trade so
teachers pay teachers is a marketplace
doing this
some teachers were making millions of
dollars just creating their uh
putting their content up for sale here
the business itself does i think 300
plus million dollars a year in revenue
and growth and gross revenue yeah
yeah it was bought by a private equity
firm and like just look at their traffic
on this thing man it's like over 30
million
yeah yeah so it's an insane business um
beautiful business too because it's like
wow you turned some teachers who created
amazing lessons and amazing tests and
quizzes you turned them into stars and
millionaires which is
fantastic i think the best teachers
should be millionaires in the age of the
internet
uh there's just no reason not that they
shouldn't be on the other side
you saved a bunch of money uh and a
bunch of sorry you saved a bunch of time
for all the other teachers so that
they're more arrested and
uh can go into class and perform instead
of being you know like kind of
falling behind constantly on the content
treadmill and so i thought this is like
you know an amazing idea same it reminds
me of the baby equipped thing obviously
this is much bigger much more successful
but it's like these
nice kind of like pain points turned
into you know marketplaces
solutions this is badass maybe you could
also do this for speeches
i uh i remember doing the uh my brother
john
um gave her wedding speeches he gave a
great best man speech
and that's a great idea three people uh
paid him money to write their speech uh
and i think that you could do that for
uh i think you could start with just
wedding speeches
but eventually do all other types of
speeches dude that is hilarious
and there's absolutely do that because
there's a ton of googling right like
when you have to give your
speech you're like oh god pressure super
high
rep like how many reps have i had doing
this zero
um okay let me go to google and let me
try to get some inspiration let's try to
get the ball rolling
people go to youtube and they try to
watch like you know best
best man speech ever right best
bridesmaid speech ever
and then you're like okay like what am i
gonna do copy this not quite
but if somebody created these with
templates um that could be pretty good i
like that yeah i actually think you
could do that there's this company
called book in a box started by tucker
max who was one of my investors
before it was uh when they did book in a
box they would you'd pay them
any number from 20 to 100 000 on a bunch
of different options and they would
write a book about your life
so you could like get speaking gigs or
you could give to your kids
or like whatever for any different
reasons you look like an expert be a
thought leader
and then a lot of their authors started
getting speech offers you know they
would someone would pay 10 20 30 000
to have someone come and talk about like
best practices and meetings because some
guy had wrote a book on
how meetings suck and how to make them
better and then they created a new
subsidiary that would write you do your
powerpoint and presentation for you and
you'd pay more money for that
and i was like that's cool that should
probably be the business more so than
just the book thing
right uh and so i think that actually
teachers paying teachers you could also
do speakers paying speakers i mean you
could do the same thing
there's another uh angle to this which
is i think that teachers are sort of
this
extremely teachers and nurses these are
two workforces that are very very large
they have a unique set of problems
they're extremely like kind of word of
mouth heavy
and i don't think that the existing
solutions were great for them so on the
podcast a long time ago we had
uh the founder of like incredible health
come on which is basically like a
kind of like a job marketplace thingy
like a kind of a link danish
i had four nurses that was right before
uh covent how'd that do
uh they raised a bunch of money i don't
know if they're doing well or not but i
can't really say but
um but they've raised a bunch of money
because the opportunity is large meaning
there are so many nurses and there's a
shortage of nurses and there's high
demand for nurses so there's nurses so
there's a lot of
fees paid for placements so nurses want
great jobs and then
hospitals and and clinics basically are
happy to pay
to place nurses and so there's a lot of
money to be made if you can build the
right
network there if you can build a
vertical linkedin for just nurses
and i think there's a similar
opportunity
for teachers not in terms of placing
teachers because it's not the same
level of demand for like hiring teachers
or but i do think that
i do think that if you build like a
professional networking thing for
teachers that's better um they don't
necessarily want or need to use linkedin
i think you could build a custom
solution that is for
teachers it's like how do teachers how
are teachers going to engage with like
kind of like their
peers all right what do they need to do
are they going to do they need to share
tips do they
are these job opportunities is it
content like teachers pay teachers
i think if you did a brainstorm if you
were in if that's that's the niche you
were in i think there's a lot of
opportunities for teachers just because
they're such a huge workforce and
the generic solution like linkedin is
not going to be tailored to them
how much do you think teachers paying
teachers got acquired for
i would say if i was gonna put a guess i
would say
500 million dollars yeah i i would i
would guess
400 500 because it is kind of a monopoly
in its niche
or more or more even if or rather if you
said it's worth more than that now i
wouldn't be surprised
yeah a week in research i didn't
research i didn't plan to bring it up
but but we can look it up it might be it
might be out there publicly
no i don't want to upload your twitter
two more uh yeah i don't have
much more what do you have i blew my
load early i have one
uh okay so we can we can end on kind of
like this life wisdom thing so
so last night uh we're hanging out we're
talking
uh you know i'm hanging out with with
some other folks who are traveling with
us
and uh yeah family members and so i i
was i
asked this question i said all right um
i said what do you think i said let's
take
fast forward you're so how old are you
31 something yeah
you're 31. i said all right fast forward
you're 90 years old
and let's say your life like you have
your life as it's gone so far and then
let's just kind of like project forward
like it just keeps going
the way that things have been going like
the on the track you're on
let's say you continue on the track you
end up at 90.
um what do you think if you look back
you're going to be most
happy with the way you lived your life
and then what do you think you're going
to regret the most about the way you
lived
your life so far and so i was curious
after i asked that question i got some
answers from the group
i was curious i was like i'm going to
ask sam this because i don't know what
he would say i think it's a hard
question to be fair
but i'm curious what comes to mind uh
for you
um i would say that i let my temper
control things you know i
i lose my temper easily sometimes you
know you've seen it sometimes when i get
mad at you or when i get mad at dan or
someone else and it's like
it's sometimes they've actually done
something that is warranted um
oftentimes it's like it's not that big a
deal and so i get
super [__] frustrated and i'll hold
grudges over like a relatively small
frustration and
i let my emotions control some of my
decisions and uh
i've lost a lot of money and a lot of
friends because of it
so that's what i regret is that and i
work quite hard to fix it but i
i wish i would have been even more aware
of that early on what else do i
do i regret that's a great answer do i
think that i'll regret
um i i wish i didn't spend years
neglecting my health thinking like oh i
can get to it
later on like i should have fun now i
wish that when i was a kid
um my parents instilled uh healthy
eating habits
because i think that like that still
kind of [__] with me right like
eating a lot of bad sugar what else um
what about the other what about the what
about the flip side what's the one thing
you're gonna look back and you'll be
like
you know glad glad that you you you
lived that way or you did that thing or
you you made those choices
starting at age 20 i wrote this down i
said
by 30 i want to i want to have started
and started something
that will make enough money that when i
have children
i won't ever have to worry about how to
give them what they need
and also i'll be able to spend time with
my family even though i didn't have a
family or anything like that i was like
that's what i think i'm gonna want by
that time i'm 30 so i'm gonna work
against that and i achieved that and so
um i'm most proud
that i now can can only worry about the
emotional aspects of the family even
though i don't even have a family
right okay i'm most proud i got that
problem out of the way
the the the financial problem what do
you think of that question is this uh is
a good question or is it it's a really
good question
i i actually changed it around i ask
myself this all the time
well it's quite similar i go i think
like how what can i do today that will
make my future self
proud and not regretful right and so
i thank myself for and and and i say 10
years but i would actually
change it to six months because often
times
how many times and the other question i
ask myself is in six months will you
wish that you have done this or wish
that you had started
trying to do blank so it's like losing
weight exercising is a really good one
sick in six months will you look back at
yourself and be like [__] i wish i
already had started learning how to
speak spanish i wish i already would
have
read these books i wish i already would
have done this so just [__] do it
make your future self proud
so um that's the question i asked i
think it's a great question and what was
your answer
what do you regret and what are you
proud of so i had trouble with the
regret side
i was thinking about it and i was like
okay i went through some i said
i couldn't think of an easy answer so i
said okay what happens when you can't
think of the answer right away
you you just start throwing out what
might it be
right so that it doesn't have to be this
but what even comes to mind
and so i was like oh well i regret kind
of like spending too much time working
okay it's possible um no i don't think
so i mean i think you got
you're pretty healthy with that you
worked really hard when you were single
or not married
yeah i work like three times harder than
i work now so something that made that
shift well
i was like will i regret um like working
on the wrong things like oh you just
worked on this
like like right now i'm building this
dvc business it's like oh well like you
know this
this frankly this is a business that's
meant to make money it's not like
the joy of my life like this podcast is
more like the joy right this is the fun
and it's building up into something
that's big but like
the business i'm doing is i'm doing it
as a business so maybe i'll say uh why
didn't i
go try to like change the world in a
bigger way maybe i'll say that i started
brainstorming these
and what i realized was that the only
things i think i'm going to regret are
either going to be health related
but even then when i by the time i'm 90
i don't know how much i'm going to care
about that if i you know if i got to 90
so
it didn't quite work but i think if i
asked that question for like 50 or 60
i would say definitely one of the top
answers would be taking care of my
health better
um you know just just prioritizing that
number one
um number two was like any when you're i
think when you're 90 you're short on
time
so you'll probably i'll probably look
back and think [__] i pissed away a
bunch of time on the wrong stuff
and so i that's what i that's the second
category is like where am i pissing away
time
that when i look back i'm gonna say i
can't believe i wasted those precious
years
on the wrong stuff or the wrong things
caring about the wrong things or even in
the moment
focusing on the wrong things the last
one is relationships it's like i think
ultimately so my answer that i came
came to in the end was i'll probably
regret not having more kids
because i think the older i get the more
joy i'm gonna have like the most
the most value and joy in my life is
just gonna come from my kids
and i know right now it feels like oh my
god i can't i couldn't plot i have two i
couldn't possibly have another because
why it's already so hard with two how's
your wife
she's young it's not the it's not the
biological clock it's like
the workload it's like oh my god like
how am i
how do i have another kid with these two
kids with
the business stuff with the podcast with
the 10 things that i do you know
and in two years you can sure
i'm not saying dylan i guess what i'm
saying is i think that's the one thing
if i look back i'm probably gonna wish i
had more kids because it's probably
gonna be
from age 65 to 90. it's probably gonna
be the number one thing
number one source of fun in my life is
gonna be my kids
i think you should uh you should address
that i told sarah i want five
and so we froze our embryos listen to
this we froze our embryos and i've got
six kids the reason
uh i don't know okay sarah's got this
sarah's got this thing
sarah's got this thing there's just a
net genetic
component that we made sure we didn't
want to pass on so the kids were healthy
and um i got five kids
all girls and so uh i'm asking her
if i can go and do it and do it again
because i would like to have two boys
two girls
right and so i've got five kids waiting
for me but they're all girls
so anyway um i actually think that
that's a good one i
asked my twitter following how many of
you uh how do you feel about kids and
age
and you almost unanimously the people
who had so this is like a
biased survey you're right so it's like
what do you mean how do you think about
kids in age what does that mean
uh i forget well i forget the exact way
that i asked it but i said do you wish
that you'd had kids sooner or later in
life
okay gotcha and uh and of course like
there's like a bias here like people who
are already bought into one category
will likely answer and support that
category or
support that decision but almost
unanimously
i feel like the answer was i wish i had
my kids sooner in life
and that actually shocked me because
particularly in new york silicon valley
la
the coastal bigger cities it's actually
versus like missouri where i'm from
it's actually more normal to get married
and have kids at 21 22 23 whereas on the
coast
coast it's like 31 32 33 and you're
constantly told you know just wait just
wait even like andrew wilkinson told me
a couple of my friends told me and i
guess you're you you have consent you
could actually give your opinion
most everyone said i wish i had kids
sooner and one guy actually changed my
perspective on everything he i go why
why do you think that he goes
because now i'm just going to die sooner
and i wish i could have spent more time
with them
yeah i don't i don't know the answer i
think whatever
i think it works either way it's not
really i don't really i don't think
there's a right answer there
but uh but i i kids are great they
critics are really great
um so so i like that question i like the
one you had too so i guess like if i was
gonna do
i recommend people do this after the
podcast if you've listened this far
i would basically write down both i
would say
what's the thing i'm gonna thank myself
for and what's the thing i'm gonna
regret when i'm 90
uh about the way i'm living my life
right now and and if i just project it
forward
and then there's the one you said which
is six months from now what's the thing
i'm going to wish i had started doing
now or stop doing now
yeah i'm still gonna wish i'd done it
then there's a lot you could do in six
months and now you're not gonna maybe
have a life-changing thing but like
you can lose 60 pounds in six months
maybe you can
um learn a little bit of a language
enough to like go and speak
maybe in a different country and you
could read a bunch of books you can
learn a new you could learn how to play
the piano in six months i mean you could
do a lot of like interesting stuff so
yeah you could go uh you know repair the
shitty relationship you have with your
dad or whatever you know you could do
you could do many many things uh i guess
that's the other one i thought about for
for
for the regret is like uh not having
maybe
spent more time or being kind of like
just like nicer to my parents like i
know i'm gonna miss them a lot when
they're gone
and they're gonna go like it's gonna
happen and
once they do i'm just gonna i think
that's probably gonna be one of the
things i'm gonna
wish why didn't i why didn't i you know
talk to him more
or spend more time or you know tell him
you know thanks you know
something like that is probably going to
be one of my answers for that
so i'll wrap this i'll wrap this up with
a quick story that hopefully will change
people's
change people's perspective so do you
know who ramit sethi is
safety he's got this business book
business slash book a huge brand called
i will teach you to be rich
he's a good friend of mine and whenever
i have money like doubts or questions i
call him and he kind of like
so for example and he always like thinks
about everything
like very thoughtfully and i was talking
to him about buying a ring from my wife
years ago and i go how much should i
spend and he goes
uh like i told him i wanted to spend 5
and he was like no no no no and he like
told me a budget way higher
he goes trust me and he explained his
reasoning and i and i listened to him i
went and bought a ring that was
i i spent 27 000 on the ring and i
didn't have
that much money what was his reasoning
though his reasoning was like
first of all it's your wife like
whatever she wants
like what's the point of working hard
it's to make someone like your wife
proud and happy and she's going to want
to show this off she'll just make her
happy
second if you're going to be married to
her for potentially 80 years who gives a
[__] over 20 grand divided by 80 grand
or 80 years um and he goes just don't be
cheap on the stuff that actually matters
this probably really matters to her now
some people doesn't matter but then the
second thing was i called for me and i
go hey ramit
you took your family to europe one time
to italy he goes yeah
uh you want me to plan yours for you and
i go well yeah but what do you mean he
goes
well like i love doing this and i'll
plan yours for you but i only have one
rule
i said what he goes i'll plan it for you
but you have to have an unlimited budget
i was like what the hell he goes
dude the whole point of traveling with
your family like you're very so i'm
taking my mom and dad and my wife to
italy my parents have really never been
out of the country other than one time
to visit me in australia
and he goes i'm gonna get you got to
give them on a limited budget i was like
dude i was gonna spend like fifteen
thousand maybe and he goes
no no no we're gonna spend 50 at least
and i was like that's so much money he
goes
dude you're never going to go out of the
country again with your family and i've
done it before
like one time it's the one thing that
they will never stop
talking about and i don't care if i only
had a hundred thousand i'm spending
fifty thousand
because this is the whole point of
working really really hard is spending
my money on stuff that will make my
family happy and they'll talk about
forever
and i was like you're right i need to
quit being a cheapskate i'm gonna just
so i bought my mom and dad first class
they've never been first class
first class tickets to europe um we're
gonna like have a great time and it kind
of changed my perspective on spending
and being tight
so that's my quick little story that's
amazing i love it alright we should we
should end on that uh
all right good episode dan what do you
think this was good i'll give you guys a
nine and a half
no okay good i'll take that last one was
an eight
but or an eight and a half all right
that's the episode
i feel like i can rule the world i know
i could be
what i want to i put my law in it like
no days off
on a road let's travel never looking
back